it turns out you're the CEO of Twitter
hypothetically
how would you make the company go
profitable
I think there's a path to doing that
medium term and long term you know
Twitter is the original short form
content it's really good at it now it's
sort of being you know computed away uh
Tick-Tock and Tick Tock should
immediately be banned of course right
and Twitter spring back Vine so there's
things to do but I think Twitter needs
to fill its feeds with longer Forum
products like I think Twitter needs to
buy Sub stack it should have built sub
stack sub stack should never be an
independent business like obviously all
these people posting on Twitter should
be able to monetize newsletters right
from in the platform and I don't mean
just the review feature that they had it
just was that was kind of bolt on wow
you should be the CEO and and like okay
so so video right Twitter sucks as a
video platform and yet YouTube has no
inherent social sort of viral social
network like Twitter does right so like
I think I think YouTube is very lucky
that no one at Twitter for the past five
years has cared about video yeah I think
I just want to make another Point here
because there's a lot of different
things that we could we could actually
do here I've been thinking about this as
well one we have super Chats on YouTube
why can't you have super Chats on
Twitter allow your comments and replies
to be voted just like Minds does mine
does does incredible things what is it
called Superman people are able to uh
put in a super chat if you answer it you
get that money that that people were
given to you that's a great thing that
mine's developed another thing that I
would recommend Twitter to do is to
essentially allow the platform to run on
its own without any kind of major money
decentralize it let people host their
own servers let people use the platform
in their own way so then even if you
don't have any money the platform still
lives on and people get to host their
content and get to communicate with
people and also be able to share their
content elsewhere and move it around
with their history of what they posted I
think those two ideas along with your
idea would be amazing videos long
overdue monetize those videos have
people I mean when we had Periscope on
YouTube this was I'm sorry a periscope
on Twitter this was a way that engaged
so many different people and then
Twitter took it down because people were
dominating it that they didn't like in
the political ideas so so so these are
just some ideas that I have off the top
of my head thank you
I don't want the responsibility get that
hot potato out of here
um one problem with videos is the cost
of the servers at least is what I'm told
and it is a big deal so we try to
decentralize it it mines like bit bit
shoot and and but it was so slow and
grainy trying to pull it from all these
other people I don't know do you know
much about decentralizing a video feeds
not technically although that's probably
going to only get better and better
right and I would look to add things
that uh people want to pay for right
like Twitter needs it's it's woefully
dependent on Advertising I'm not saying
advertising goes away but it needs to uh
certainly have new new revenue streams
where creators are getting paid for
their content you know what I realize
I'm paying eight bucks a month for
Twitter blue I am so happy to do that
right now I pay 40 bucks a year or
something on mines to have the uh
upgraded mines I'm not sure what it's
called exactly sorry Bill mine's Pro
mine's Pro to be on mines Pro and it's
like having a Netflix I don't have
Netflix account I don't watch Disney I
don't have those accounts I pay for the
social networks that I love that's where
I like to I would pay 15 bucks a month
on Twitter for sure for all those
benefits to be able to post long videos
to be able to make you a video like at
TAG Elon Musk hey man what's happening
bro
um that that access to this hey DMs I
think Elon talked about totally it's
great it's been Twitter's made it really
hard over the past few years for people
to actually make a business on Twitter
yeah I I think YouTube's done much
better in this in this version blocked
link sharing recently and kind of
backpedaled on it link sharing there was
like you can't link to your whatever
your other social Bible social media
which is actually YouTube does the same
thing I believe twitch does the same
thing I believe Facebook Facebook
blocked Minds do they still block mines
dude Microsoft blocks mines it's very
weird
announces this uh this new policy where
it's like you can't use Twitter to just
promote other platforms and everyone
loses their mind and it's like YouTube's
always had that rule so like if you made
a video like subscribe to my Twitter
account and that was the title of the
video that yeah they'd nuke you so
here's what I'm saying I think they
mentioned paid DMs I got a lot of people
who hate me and they'll pay a lot of
money to set to say nasty things to me
and I will take their money and they can
so 100 bucks I will I will set my my
paid DMS at a hundred dollars and then
all the people who hate me can say all
the nasty things in the world and I will
monetize that and you have to respond
and then Twitter gets a small cut of it
well I don't know about responding just
fill up my mailbox well I mean like
people could do that yeah
you can't DM me I've closed DMS okay so
if they if he made paid direct messaging
I would say okay you want to direct
message me and I don't follow you 100
bucks you know and then you can send me
whatever nasty garbage you want you got
to pay me to do it and then a very
monetize the hate but you don't have to
read it you got to read it to get the
money you got to open the email that's
what I said I accept
I will read the comment of someone
saying you know Pim tool is a bald fool
or something like that if it's a hundred
bucks so what a totally worth I brought
this up before earlier reverse only fans
like a crypto token at Twitter mine says
a Minds token that's a utility token
that functions on the network you can
put a token into the network to get a
thousand views of publicity um then you
can buy the tokens and uh but I know
like you were saying earlier like SEC
violations you got to watch out for like
Library got raked for SEC violations I
don't know the exact but miles either so
the risk with the FEC is if they don't
like your politics well hey that token
is a security and that's just arbitrary
Elizabeth Warren could come up with some
justification for why yours is different
but like the justification is she hates
you and once you cry if all it does is
get you publicity on the network that
it's sold on
um and then maybe used for fun cosmetic
stuff on the network I just don't see
any security involved in that it's all
utility at that point
I think you're right but they'll argue
it anyway yeah so you want to be on the
other side of the FEC uh enforcement
action because I think that could take
the company very profitable or at least
Elite very very very profitable I mean
obviously what would happen is the
Twitter token would become super
valuable and it would become traded on
binance and stuff and then they might
say hey and then it's a security camera
yeah maybe yeah punished with your own
success but it's interesting though to
think how much they could raise if they
did that
and that's that's not even that's just
the IPO or the Ico you're talking about
initial coin offering they could raise
money for I think then that might be a
security because mines didn't do an Ico
that's a big part of it that's right
they just make tokens and then sell them
and then you use them on the network
there's no there's no uh there's no
public investment the investment is you
buy the token
what do you think of the future man you
feeling optimistic
um not by default but I'm not not a
Doomer either you know I really think
it's contingent it matters what we do
and and why wouldn't it like human
agency is really important if you're up
if you're too optimistic and like oh
things will just work out well you're
probably not going to work as hard in
making that happen and then if you're
just fatalistic oh man it sucks oh I
just lost my election that sucks
everything's doomed no somehow that
doesn't feel quite right either it's
like your mind's scary but we got to
work hard your mindset and positivity
does matter when it comes to your
overall productivity and what you're
able to do in life but at the same time
you got to be realistic with all the
problems and I totally agree with you
you got to have a balance between
between the two and have a certain level
of of uh you know basis in reality but
also some optimism on top of that you
know you know it gave me a lot of a lot
of optimism was the judge granting
Carrie Lakes uh trial
I mean because everything we've seen in
the past has been dismissed dismissed
dismissed these judges have been weak
and just I don't want to deal with it
I'm not saying this judge is going to do
the right thing in terms of well I I'm
not going to say the judge is going to
give us what we want but the fact the
trial happened at all I think was a
major step forward in terms of
confidence so I'm feeling good I think
the night is always darkest before the
dawn I think what we're seeing with uh
James Lindsay you know the things he's
calling out and exposing with continued
success his his right his growing
prominence calling out the the groomer
phenomenon and I think Elon Musk buying
Twitter it's kind of like it's never
been better to be completely honest it's
true that didn't have to happen yeah and
if he didn't do that we never would have
got the Twitter files right that means
what the coming installments will be and
uh look I have I have tremendous faith
in in the inherent goodness and I guess
just common sensical nature of the
American people and most people
worldwide and we have a political
establishment I think left and right
that is corrupt and doesn't work and
those things don't go together so how
long is the pendulum I don't know
hopefully things don't have to get that
much worse before they get better but I
do think yeah they'll get better and and
we've seen I think ebb and flow in human
history right I think we've got to work
hard to tighten up that uh what's the
technical term for the length of a
pendulum I don't know whatever it is
let's make it short but the diameter but
but I think it is getting better I think
I think we're on the the backswing it's
starting to come back I hope so I think
with uh conservatives starting to uh
recognize the power of ballot harvesting
and ballot chasing I think 2024 is going
to be a game changer it's like it's like
you were saying it's about raw numbers
they're going up for the raw numbers
it's not about the messaging for
Democrats about the raw numbers for
Republicans it's going to be both
because Republicans a lot of Republican
voters are higher information voters
than Democrats that's why Democrats want
16 year old voters they want low
information well Democrats will vote for
John Federman
you know where some of our voters God
bless them and we gotta work hard to
persuade them
um but some of them is like well I read
some bad things about Blaker I saw this
TV commercial for that it's like well
I I appreciate the individuality in our
party and we have a lot more diversity
in our party actually in terms of
diversity of thought but the Democrats
will vote for fetterman or anything a
rock you guys got a D next to its name
and that's a challenge that we have to
overcome but but I think the Republicans
just need to Target those people these
these people who are low information
voters voting Democrat aren't voting
Democrat for any good reason which means
Republicans could win those votes they
just aren't exactly you need to show up
what do you think about like refocusing
a message we've talked about this for
sure too like graphene or some sort of
industrialization message of making the
United States an industrial superpower
just just a just a real quick preface
that like I think the point of the
conversation is that messaging is is
immaterial but again you know your
thoughts I think I think it matters
though and um you know while we're
working hard to go in in a legal way of
course you know Harvest ballots that
collect ballots
um I think interesting messaging does
matter for one like why aren't we
focusing more on nuclear power you know
earlier I only had so many campaign
dollars and we had to talk about border
and inflation and those are the top two
two issues but but every you know stump
speech I try to find a way to work in
nuclear power it's like this isn't even
new technology it's like old technology
that for bizarre reasons countries like
Germany have decommissioned right we
have about 50 uh nuclear power plants in
the United States nowhere near enough
most of them are decades old and so if
you care about climate change if you
care about you know Carbon free energy
generation why are we not going all in
on nuclear and when I would mention
nuclear power it was actually somewhat
of an unexpected Applause line and some
very right-wing Republican rooms like
obviously not going to get rid of oil
and gas we need to be drilling we need
to be fracking it's like all above uh
kind of approach is appropriate for the
next few decades but man 50 years from
now 80 of our power should be generally
traded from from nukes at least at the
path we're going we'll probably have new
technology like vacuum vibrational
things infusion power which is a they
call it nuclear it's a completely
different technology than fission so
there you can't really call them both
nuclear it's a misknown we got to lean
into Innovation yeah as the broader
points like we should be agnostic about
what it is but like what it isn't is you
know some dumb subsidy for some wind
thing that is not even gonna work I
think what's happening you remember the
tech in Texas two years ago was it last
year the Deep Freeze that ruined all
these these wind power these these
windmills or whatever they're called
wind generators uh and we're headed in
like four a few days for another Deep
Freeze in Texas I'm told this is
terrifying people died people froze to
death in their houses because they had
shut down coal plants leading up to this
and I think that's why people are like
yes nuclear yes heat yes because it gets
cold if it goes down to 45 degrees in
your house nothing really matters other
than some heat that's right I think I
think Americans would be here for
whether it's a new party if you could
somehow bootstrap that into existence or
a Republican party that was like Hey
we're the party of competence We're the
Party of Technology we're the party of
families We're the Party of sane trade
deals and and you know the party that
doesn't want to get into Wars halfway
around the world I think people would be
into that I think it's like we need
Charisma too like I used to think I was
telling you earlier like I was like oh I
didn't actually mention you were saying
you're a republican we were younger I
was like a Democrat when I was younger I
like I went after Charisma I was always
drawn to like Bill Clinton because you
like Howard Dean no no was that fair
point yeah Bill Clinton Barack Obama I
like the dudes that could make you feel
good and it's only later I'm realizing
like oh I've been snowed this whole time
man they were making me feel good to get
me to get me to pay my dollar so but I
do think we need to introduce Charisma
but the thing is like Luke you were
saying don't vote for political parties
I don't care about the party I don't I
thought in 2007 we don't need parties
anymore man we just need someone that's
willing to step up and do the work
you're right but that I I don't think um
takes into consideration the political
reality that there are a lot of people
who won't vote outside of the two-party
system out of fear of not winning and
that has a substantial impact the
libertarian party does a great job of
getting a lot of people of principle to
vote for the libertarian party but they
they don't they don't move the needle
what do you think did you just do it
enough and how did Abe Lincoln win look
the Maga party is not the same as the
Republicans and that's why there's a
republican Civil War at least what the
media calls it the reason why I think
the establishment didn't support you is
because you're you know Blake you're
more libertarian you're outside the
Republican Party
in in a in a literal in in a in a
intangible sense like quite literally a
Republican but as far as the
establishment Republicans are concerned
the modern Republicans are a different
party and they're an Insurgent group
coming in
that's right and we're going to get an
interesting
um I guess case study here Kirsten
cinema right the other Democrat senator
from uh Arizona just announced I think a
week or two ago she's going to be an
independent oh yeah I think probably
because she read the polls and realized
with her voting record it'd be
impossible for her to win a Democratic
primary so now she's daring yeah the
Democrat establishment to run a Dem
against her I thought that was also at
the race into a three-way race which I
actually think would favor a republican
so we'll see how it shakes out but can a
independent actually make a real go of
it right I mean Bernie Sanders caucuses
with the Democrats but of course
technically he's an independent
Force the Democrats to keep her on as
their candidate when when Cinema said
she was an independent they they
immediately knew they could not run
anyone else and they can't primary her
they have no choice but to get behind
her well we'll see if they have that
kind of discipline I think Schumer wants
the situation you outline but this other
Congressman Reuben Gallegos sort of
communist guy from from Phoenix
he really wants to get in and I hope he
does right and then you know grab the
popcorn are you gonna are you gonna run
again if Gallego gets in then that gives
me a lot to think about because in the
freeway race I will win or I would I
would beat guy I go one on one when
would that be like four four years or
what oh no no 2024 2024 yeah Cinema's up
in 2024. and so you could put the demos
might yeah but the Dems might actually
have enough discipline to keep her keep
a Dem out I think you should run anyway
hey there you go she's tough to beat
she's tough but Mark Kelly was tough to
beat though right and I think um you
know some people say oh Blake you lost
by five it's like Oz lost by five in
Pennsylvania and he had a way worse
opponent and 30 million dollars for
Mitch McConnell right so I think in a
different year
um with the you know and look I made
some mistakes too like I didn't run a
perfect campaign and I've been
self-critical about that and next time I
do it I will tell you this I will be
better and I will win I live in West
Virginia I instantly like Cinema more
than Mansion because she because she
comes out as an independent and Mansion
is still playing this ridiculous game of
being a democrat in literal Maga country
what's gonna happen there I feel like
he's now he's underwater right I think
he's gonna is he just gonna switch I
think he's gonna switch to being a
republican he was asked and he said you
know something like we'll wait till
later talk about it or something like
that which made everyone immediately be
like okay he's mansion's gonna switch
this is I think West Virginia is like 86
Trump supporting yeah you know every
County I think in 2020.
absurdly high you know I I where where I
live in West Virginia it's right-wing
nut jobs who believe every single
conspiracy theory you can think of I
mean these are people who are Trump
trump hands down and then you say
mansion and they go oh like he's
supposed to be on our side and it's not
even about the name of the party they
feel like he's not representing them
properly nut jobs a term of endearment
by the way it is yeah like when you when
you go to West Virginia and you say I
love living on a mountain full of
right-wing nut jobs they all laugh and
smile because it's like it's taking the
word back you know I mean they say if
you're sane in an insane world you're
actually you look insane you look like a
nutshell we we had we had we had a
break-in recently
I think it was targeted but I tweeted I
was like you got to be insane to break
into a house in West Virginia especially
if it's like a political thing and I was
like just imagine breaking into a house
and there's some right-wing nut job with
a Barrett M82 pointed at you yelling
Yeehaw and like all the people out here
are laughing at the idea because they
love it they love it they're like that's
us you know don't don't come and
knocking if you don't want to see what's
on the other side do you think Blake do
you think the solution to I don't know
what what do you what is your end goal
really with the United States or in your
lifetime how would you like to see the
United States develop
I I think one litmus test for or are we
on the right track is is politics boring
again like I think politics should be
boring it shouldn't be what people are
investing all their time and emotional
energy into I would like uh campaign on
the slogan to me it's more than the
slogan but it is I think a good
political slogan in America you should
be able to raise a family on one single
income I think if we got back to an
economy where you could actually do that
maybe it's really hard in a globalizing
world but man if you could just if young
people had Economic Opportunity and were
you know on net choosing to get married
and have kids in their 20s and we're
able to buy and afford homes and people
didn't have to be obsessed with politics
right we weren't at each other's throats
all the time I think that would be
really healthy do you see how politics
is pop culture right now yeah that's
right that's really messed up yeah it's
really messed up was um what was his
name Schumer was dancing with Stephen
Colbert did you see that video they were
unfortunately I did see that I had
forgotten about it I did it you said
earlier like it's a it's a worldwide
movement I think you mentioned that
earlier but I sense like worldwide that
humans want freedom they the First
Amendment of the United States
Constitution is like one of the most
inspirational governmental actions ever
taken on Earth and I feel like we have
so many people from Australia that watch
the show and England and all these great
countries that unfortunately get can get
arrested for standing outside of
someone's house uh and I hope that maybe
that they're I I kind of see like a
United States of Earth where we have
like state rights still but we just are
have like a form of kind of a sort of
Unified Government I don't know if
that's two pieces globalist in a way I
mean I like I think inevitably we're
globalizing I just want it to be done
right I want it to be done so that we
maintain our Bill of Rights like a
republic where the United States has
Sovereign borders where we control our
own government but there is some kind of
legislative system externally that can't
interfere internally with the nation but
can help prevent Wars yeah and even Ohio
still has its Sovereign borders and
right every state still has its own
rights like Alberta for instance I think
there's an Alberta secession movement
right now Alberta becomes a state of the
United States of Earth and then
we just keep growing from there and then
everyone lives under the Constitution
yeah but the Constitution's malleable
but yes yeah I think the Bill of Rights
for sure maybe I I think it's a good
idea maybe in order to to get to that
point you know some people will have to
be made to understand so perhaps we
could like put together a group of
people with perhaps weapons that could
go in and tell these people they now
live under our way of life and uh we we
we would call it like a Liberation we
would send out Liberation forces to
others that's horribly
commonly goes back to Woodward Wilson
right the League of Nations exactly now
it's the U.N and let's just have a a
layer on top that will help it and it's
like well the danger is that you know
that that layer becomes incredibly
bureaucratic and powerful and it gets
more power for itself and pretty soon I
think this is where the the century is
trending if we don't uh resist it you
get a one world totalitarian government
I like the idea of like China wants to
build its version and China wants
everyone to be Chinese in 100 years and
uh we actually nope we've never figured
out a way to to do that in a safe way
and I think we should look towards
decentralization thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time